mean Kazumi sent me a link to a book
about polyamorous relationships that
because I've never read about it or
researched it or even really thought
about it because me and my girl are not
Polly in that sense like we just do porn
with other people we do it for Content
yeah you know even like my girl
yesterday like we were on the Jason Lee
podcast and she just kind of said like
yeah you know if you were on a trip and
you ended up [__] some girl as long
as you told me like or or as long as you
were safe about it I don't think I would
really care that much I'm like wow like
you're Progressive your mind is changing
a bit because I remember when me and her
first got in the relationship she made
it very clear like you're on tour I'm
not really [__] with that anymore
like I'm Gonna Leave You if you just
[__] somebody I'm cheating right yeah
like it's actual cheating you know but
like apparently she's kind of softened
up on that a bit although I don't really
trust these hoes enough to even do that
I don't want to be in a hotel room alone
with a girl I don't trust these [__]
at all not even that they're just gonna
lie they're gonna say that I did
something you know and that's why even
if I was gonna shoot porn with just me
and another girl I would definitely have
like a real filmer so at least I could
have you have a witness yeah